all right so let's do um one more sort
of awkward moment in the aftermath to
the colin powell death that we reported
on yesterday i mentioned in the first
segment
how fox news reporter john roberts
tweeted something completely insane
about the death in vaccines and then
quickly deleted it well it got even
weirder when then fox news brought on a
guest to talk about people that are
reacting and saying things that are
wrong and john roberts was sitting there
very awkwardly as dr nicole safier was
essentially describing what john roberts
said without actually naming him so
let's let's kind of like refresh this
entire thing uh john roberts tweeted
yesterday after the death of colin
powell was announced the fact that colin
powell died from a breakthrough covet
infection
raises new concerns about how effective
vaccines are long-term now that's not
true
we knew that immunocompromised people
like colin powell would mount less on
average of an immune response
we know that the older you are in colin
powell was 84
the more likely you are to die from
covid
um
obviously that goes down with being
vaccinated but vaccinated populations
the older you are the more likely you
are to die from covet and unvaccinated
as well it's sort of a distribution that
is like that so john roberts quickly
deleted this tweet
so then fox news brings on dr nicole
safier
and john roberts is on screen
and nicole savier says this doesn't mean
the vaccines don't work this stuff has
to stop a lot of people are spreading
nonsense and john roberts looking very
uncomfortable because she doesn't name
him but he had just gotten done tweeting
this nonsense and then deleting it
something that you want to get out there
in the wake of colin powell's death that
you want people to know
because obviously there's a lot of
information to take in on this final
thought from you
well i can tell you sandra you know it's
very it's very upsetting to see that
people taking um colin powell's death
and using it as the vaccine didn't work
oh well that's exactly what john roberts
did and now he's going to sit there and
listen to you this is a very specific
situation and one to use someone's death
to try and make a point that really
doesn't carry a lot of weight to it oh
that's exactly what john roberts was
doing he was trying to make a point that
carries no weight using colin powell's
death is is
very frustrating but i can tell you that
this was a very specific situation you
had an elderly gentleman i i know that
people don't like that word but at the
age of 84 he was already vulnerable for
covet 19 and then you add a cancer of
the blood and he is the most vulnerable
when it comes to covenant 19.
our thoughts with his family for sure at
this moment after learning of his death
this morning yeah yeah john roberts oh
yeah very much yes of course well he's
the guy who just did exactly that he
looked uncomfortable
and he should look uncomfortable
and it is
it is an instructive lesson in
if we already know
that while the vaccine reduces your risk
of hospitalization and death
dramatically it is not 100
and then one well-known person dies
it actually changes nothing it it
changes nothing about our overall
understanding of the vaccine's
effectiveness it's just we know the name
of this person
it's a well-known person that's what it
changes and these i don't know if
they're opportunists
i don't know if they're simply ignorant
i don't know if they're bad people who
use this as uh they see it as opening
the door to tweet exactly what john
roberts tweeted which he was then later
shamed or someone called him and said
you really should pull that down
it is not serious thinking these are not
serious contributions to our
understanding of how vaccination works
and they shouldn't be considered that
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will all
of my viewers will get up to 200 off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video